[Music]
from this desk seven and a half years
ago President Bush announced the
beginning of military operations in Iraq
much has changed since much has changed
since Bush announced the beginning of
Operation Iraqi Freedom this is an
anti-war protest in Hollywood in 2003 it
was big it was noisy even Martin Sheen
was there this gathering in Santa Monica
is more typical of the present day
anti-war movement or there's the
occasional cluster of street corner
protesters these ones are so committed
they're protesting in the rare Los
Angeles rain Ian Thompson is a member of
the ansar coalition one of the
left-leaning anti-war groups still
actively protesting the wars was very
big in the lead up to the Iraq war it
was the biggest in world history in fact
the New York Times said the anti-war
movement was the other superpower
counter to the US and so I'd say now
it's definitely smaller but a lot of
people's minds have changed what 60% of
the people being against the Afghanistan
war shouldn't be a surprise but it's a
call to action to say that you don't
have to just sit there and take it you
can do something and that's part of what
we're trying to do what anti-war
protester heel puppet penetration I have
not even I have heard of none Thaddeus
Russell is a historian and author of a
renegade history of the United States
the anti-war movement since Obama took
office has largely disappeared
attendance at anti-war rallies has
declined steadily since 2003 and
precipitously in 2008 I see not a lot of
difference between a
as foreign policy in George Bush's I
will promise you this that if we have
not gotten our troops out by the time I
am president it is the first thing I
will do I will get our troops home we
will bring an end to this war candidate
Obama repeatedly promised to end the war
in Iraq I have been very specific and
saying that we will not have permanent
bases there I will end the war as we
understand it in combat mission although
he has ended what he calls combat
operations close to 50,000 troops remain
on bases in Iraq Obama has increased
troop levels in Afghanistan by more than
30,000 and for the most part continued
george w bush's policies in the Middle
East
yet 78% of Democrats approved of Obama's
foreign policy in 2010 back in 2003 only
22 percent approved of Bush's very
similar foreign policy the Left merged
its identity with a man who was about to
assume the mantle of the American Empire
that's who became the left and they
became him and now it becomes very
difficult to challenge him because of
that
since Obama's inauguration the
proportion of unaffiliated voters at
anti-war rallies has been on the rise
meanwhile the proportion of Democrats
has dropped it's sad to say but in the
Obama era it is now looking like a lot
of what we thought was a powerful and
rigorous anti-war movement really turned
out to be more the ongoing powerful and
rigorous anti Republican Party and I
George Bush movement Brian Doherty is a
senior editor at Reason magazine and
author of radicals for capitalism it is
depressing to me how few of President
Obama's fervent fans see this disconnect
you will still see them driving around
with their Obama with the O is a peace
sign bumper stickers it's not just his
American vans who fail to see the
disconnect Obama was handed the Nobel
Peace Prize just nine days after
announcing he'd be sending 30,000 more
troops to Afghanistan when he won the
Nobel were upheld war prize the Nobel
Peace Prize you know he made actually a
declaration of war against the world I
understand why
is not popular but I also know this the
belief that peace is desirable is rarely
enough to achieve it
I believe that force can be justified on
humanitarian grounds any nation that
threatens its civilians in ways that we
deemed to be not humanitarian we have
the right to intervene militarily all
responsible nations must embrace the
role that militaries with a clear
mandate can play to keep the peace some
protesters like the libertarians who
organized this rally and Santa Monica
have kept policy ahead of personality an
armed neutral national defense instead
of you know foreign adventurism the
United States has been has had a habit
of intervening in other countries when
there's no need for it to do so
libertarians can feel a certain point of
pride in being not bipartisan but extra
partisan they are not concerned with the
team flag whoever's running the
government they're concerned with the
policies of government libertarians for
that reason have been consistently since
the modern libertarian movement began a
loud force against war and some on the
Left have been consistent - there's no
significant difference really I think
between the foreign policy the Bush
administration and the Obama
administration the very similar they
have you know not met any of the goals
like shutting Guantanamo Bay which was
an Obama promise people should be out
regardless of who's in the White House
but these protesters aren't exactly
moderate Democrats and looked at places
like Venezuela places in Latin America
that are breaking away from u.s.
imperialism and if
places like you but strikes me is
unfortunate when people who are
ostensibly trying to create a mass
anti-war movement mix up their anti-war
feelings with their other political
beliefs whether it be leftist and and
health care and education reform or or
even the Ron Paul team who are great on
foreign policy issues but of course also
have a set of larger libertarian issues
monetary policy issues Federal Reserve
issues if the anti-war movement doesn't
focus its message the bipartisan warfare
state will likely continue but the
people who populate the anti-war
movement today are kind of on the
fringes of American politics and so on
the left you have hardcore socialists
and on the right you have libertarians
there's almost no one in its Center who
is really putting any energy into
stopping these wars
the thing about wars and politics is
wars generally they're started
bipartisanly they're supported by
partisan Lee their continued bipartisan
Lee the Republican worth today is going
to be the Democratic war of tomorrow and
the way things are going in Iraq and
Afghanistan will probably live to see
that Democratic war become a Republican
war again
[Music]